el oficialismo como ya lo decíamos ganó
en la mayoría de los estados cuáles son
las razones para esta victoria tan
contundente
hola qué tal la maría clara pues muchas
gracias por el foro en torno a eso que
preguntas pues es interesante ver el
tema de la oposición es clave entender
que en las últimas elecciones las
últimas tres elecciones particularmente
la oposición había hecho un llamado a
que la gente no saliera a votar como
parte de las protestas en torno a el
régimen de maduro sin embargo en esta
ocasión sí sí lanzaron el llamado para
que fueran a participar pero sí de todas
maneras hubo confusión de parte de los
que apoyan a la posición y esto rédito
en que el 40% de la población
participará en estas elecciones
lo cual pues es es una señal irrelevante
en torno a lo que podría ser una
elección adelantada
en torno a las negociaciones para la
presidencia o en el 2025 no que todavía
es un largo camino por recorrer pero
bueno si es una muestra en torno a la
fricción o la falta de consolidación de
una oposición
a los comunicados que se le dan a sus
aliados y apoyo de la población ustedes
ya lo decía que la oposición lleva tres
elecciones llamando a la abstención y
promoviendo boicots y también hablaba de
la profunda división en la oposición a
qué se debe estas diferencias internas
pues en parte es
en todo lo que hace a resultado no a los
éxitos que han tenido la posición los
últimos años que han sido bastante
limitados
claro debido a las acciones del régimen
de maduro en contra de la posición en
términos de lo de las negociaciones que
se han realizado incluso entre los que
están expatriados en otros países y la
persecución obviamente no hacia los
opositores que estoy un poco
imposibilitado no de la oposición
presentaron un frente claro y conseguir
apoyo internacional que justamente estas
elecciones fueron clave porque contaron
con una participación de la unión
europea después de más de 15 años por 15
años que no que no habían logrado
participar como observadores en estas
elecciones entonces pues bueno esto esto
va a dar mayor legitimidad a esta a
estas elecciones y por esto era clave no
que la posición pudiera consolidarse en
torno a pues mandar por lo menos un
mensaje claro sobre si deben participar
o no apoyo